star stepped out in style for the 91st
annual Academy Awards but the
festivities really started after the
camera stopped rolling at this year's
host less Oscars Ash there were
champagne showers major PDA celebs were
letting loose at the after-party and eat
see has an inside look at the
star-studded events
I drew the field because everybody has
just assumed that you've had a meal you
don't want to ask for nominations
because you're that good good time for
directing first best picture that's kind
of crazy though you should've gotten
here before now before stepping out to
both the Vanity Fair and Governor's Ball
Spike Lee celebrated his big win on the
stage with this iconic group Wesley
Snipes Will Smith and Denzel Washington
who was not pictured in this photo great
but fern after-after-party after so uh I
got a I got my my my booking brother
jay-z but he's a great night great night
inside the Governor's Ball the black
clansmen director was livin it up he
entered the party with a large group of
people and appeared to be having a good
time
just after he shaded cream booked for
its Best Picture win can you give us
your thoughts on that Best Picture win
let me take another sip
next question I thought was courtside at
the Garden the ref made a bad call whoa
now what you may have missed on TV
blackish star Jennifer Lewis going
barefoot before the ceremony started she
yelled this the shoes I kind of agree
with her later and I witnessed lzt the
actress was spotted slipping on
flip-flops at the Governor's Ball as she
hung out with shangela and drank red
wine also a vibe what is gonna happen to
you when you meet Barbra Streisand
I don't know I think your husband's
gonna have to remove his wedding ring
because I may jump back you're not gonna
break any laws trying to beat Aria I
went break any laws now this was a dream
come true for Richard II grant as he met
his woman crush Barbra Streisand after
the Oscars he tweeted pics of the
exchange and said he had a quote proper
conversation
now despite taking a tumble off the
stage after accepting his award rami
malek appeared to be in great spirits
and showed no signs of injuries I don't
like to pull the Freddy moves out much
but if there's ever a night and over at
the Vanity Fair party we were up all
night waiting for that photo of Taylor
Swift and Joe Allen it never came oh my
gosh so Joe poster photos solo while
Taylor showed off her fringe dress and
high pony on Instagram little bump that
deserves a high res perfect lighting
shot that dress was like we needed a red
carpet moment yeah agreed
okay now someone that did step out in
style newlyweds Nick and Priyanka Jonas
look red carpet ready and they packed on
the PDA on that Stefon repeat Priyanka
Jonas another couple arrived together in
style check this out Melissa McCarthy
and Ben Falcone in matching tracksuits
whose idea was this
I just thought cuz we were like should
we change and I was like oh I have an
idea but I will say when I heard that I
was like oh god yes 150 percent yes
let's do this you're my best dress best
dress at the Vanity Fair Oscar party
Melissa and Ben ladies and gentlemen
even with a sneaker you know some big
diamonds I'm not kidding around I
doubled whatever had on the Oscars I
doubled so now it's like I wouldn't
trust me with it now inside one of my
favorite parts ash is that they serve
1,700 in-n-out burgers something Jon
Hamm told 80 was his reason for
attending and I'm right there with him
I am very jealous cuz I went to
McDonald's last night and it was close I
thought that was a 24-hours
establishment for upsetting anyway
perhaps the best photo of the night has
to go to Lady Gaga and Madonna it seems
like they've buried that hatchet they
pose cuddled up at Madonna's super
secret Oscars after-party I love this oh
my god their dreams over at the Elton
John party Paris Hilton seemed to have a
great time inside she was spotted
dancing along to cardi B and of course
taking selfies I mean who else in money
moves no no it's great
yeah
I love Elton I think he is such an
incredible person and all the work that
his foundation does is just amazing it's
been 27 years now and it's always such a
special night to not only celebrate the
Oscars but also giving back but the
highlight of Elton John was of course
Elton John he and Taron Egerton who was
playing him in the upcoming biopic
Rocket Man performed tiny dancer and it
was magical
take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
always feels important playing someone
who is so universally adored but also
when you know someone you kind of fall
in love with them as a friends you it
feels that much more important to do a
good job these things everything in the
film it's not like Bohemian Rhapsody
well that was lip sync Terrence sings
everything so and I've heard what he
sound because they played it to me and
it's extraordinary I am due to see the
film in the next couple of weeks so I'll
have a few handkerchiefs ready at
probably ok there will be much more
coming from Oscar night to stick to et
online for updates until next time I'm a
- Carlsen and I met Courtney underscore
tez Annelle bye for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]